le meeting politique l'incontournable
des campagnes présidentielles
aujourd'hui tout est calculé scénarisé
ça peut nous sembler banal mais dans les
années 60 rien de tout ça pas de mise en
scène ou le strict minimum tenez en 1969
meeting à boulogne de jacques duclos le
candidat communiste à la présidentielle
difficile de l'apercevoir temps il est
noyé au milieu de la foule
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes des citoyens
et le 1er juin
vous aurez appelle un choix dans les
années 70 le meeting devient vraiment un
outil de communication regardez le
contraste à gauche élections
présidentielles de 1965 le candidat
socialiste françois mitterrand est en
meeting dans une petite salle à lille
avec deux micros à droite toujours
françois mitterrand candidat en 1974 une
grande salle à paris on ne compte plus
les micros le candidat socialiste l'a
bien compris le meeting c'est avant tout
un outil de communication peut-être
serais-je bientôt le président de la
république française à partir des années
80 les meetings prennent encore plus
d'ampleur médiatique à la télé ça
devient une guerre d'image
1981 françois mitterrand toujours et son
dernier meeting présidentiel dans un
stade plein à craquer à toulouse et ils
donnent tout
vidéoprojection son nom inscrit sur la
pelouse est une innovation
innovation dans un meeting politique et
un militant traduisait les propos de
l'orateur pour les malentendants à
bientôt ce fut le dernier mot de cette
campagne du premier tour
le meeting politique c'est aussi le d
retraçons force un moyen d'impressionner
l'opinion et la concurrence bref il faut
en faire toujours plus que son rival
2007 à paris le candidat ump nicolas
sarkozy met les moyens des écrans géants
des caméras par dizaines une foule
compacte une scénographie très
sophistiqué
l'énorme machine tourne à plein régime
et ça peut aller encore plus loin dix
ans plus tard en 2017 jean luc mélenchon
se multiplient oui vous avez bien
compris pour le candidat insoumis ce
n'est pas 1 ni 2 ou 3 1 7 meetings
simultanée dans cette ville différente
apparaît
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout ça grâce à une technique inédite
dans un meeting politique en france
l'hologramme
bref il est loin le temps des meetings
des années 60 aujourd'hui le meeting
politique reste un élément de
communication essentiel pour les
candidats à la présidentielle des images
aujourd'hui contrôlé car très souvent
tourné par les équipes de campagne des
prétendants à l'elysée
[Musique]